my talk is about applications in a
computer region using Mathematica 10 i'm
using Mathematica 10.2 for this
demonstration I think by now everybody
has heard about computer vision even if
the name is unknown you know computer
vision is pretty much be quitters you
switch on your TV you see the weather
channel there's some computer vision to
remove the green background and put some
of a map on it if there is picture in
the car and you your car will show you a
camera with when you back out see where
if you're standing next to a wall or
something this is again an application
special effects Hollywood etc so
computer vision is is very varied in
scope in this talk I will give an idea
of what's available to perform computer
vision applications in mathematica 10
and I would go through three
applications one on texture
classification another one and a
straightening of images and also on
death map estimation from stereo vision
so the first one would be a very much
classic modern diamond classic standard
application that has been around for
four why then we move on to a more
modern task about here touching geometry
and computational photography and then
this again about geometry this time
using two images so before I start
whenever I talk about computer vision I
always try to design be great quickly
the the confusion if you browse through
books about computer vision you can
think that computer vision is image
processing it's machine learning extra
everybody is their own definition so as
far as as we are concerned in
Mathematica all these topics that we
categorize as image processing actually
would be long as well to computer vision
so the ability you have from Mathematica
to acquire live images from
from remote devices or connected to your
computer the ability to do all types of
filtering to your images what we have in
the feature detection where you try to
find some little information that you
hope later on to aggregate into some
meaning of some knowledge of the world
that you're hoping to discover
segmentation we have a frozen in for a
while in mathematical world set of
functionality registration is a task
that is also quite common in many
applicable vision applications for
stitching for example so a mathematical
propos offers for a while alignment
based on feature and those as well as
dance estimation of geometric
transformation between pair of images
more recently we have introduced
functionality in computational
photography there will be a talk by my
colleague Judy alessandra near later
this week I think tomorrow and you will
hear about tone mapping exposure
bracketing focus bracketing in painting
was there for a while background removal
so this is a this is ready for you my
talk is about computer vision
applications these applications they
already they're part of the system so
you don't need to do anything and
finally i'm sure you have you ever heard
about image identify recently so this is
a guess the most bleeding edge in the
image recognition detection but we we
have face detection OCR and barcode
recognition for what the in the domain
of machine learning this will also this
belongs to this talk as well what
mathematical affairs for clustering
nearest neighbor search classification
prediction this functionality and very
modern deep conversion or network that
is coming up dimensionality reduction
these topics are very valuable for some
applications of computer vision
as a mathematica being this one system
one umbrella system where everything is
under the same roof you will enjoy now
development in geometry regents this can
get you out of trouble in a variety of
situation so that being said let's now I
would like to present what you can do
with the system not so much to see the
features in themselves the documentation
is there for that so let's move on to
the first application which is about
texture classification what I'm showing
here is a something that you can think
of as a classic I'm not sure in two
years anyone will we still want to talk
about that but currently that's that's a
classic way of doing texture
classification and the idea is that you
have given an image of a texture so this
will be a such typical image the texture
is essentially an image that free BTW
with a small pattern that repeats itself
so the the main idea here is that we are
going to this to engineer features that
describe this image the relationship
between neighboring pixels in that image
so in order to do that we use to record
the co-occurrence matrix and if i if i
show you how such metrics look here i
have asked for essentially i'm looking
at this is like a 2d histogram and i'm
looking at relationship between a pixel
between neighboring pixels here left and
right and what this tells me is unsure
that if I'm all on the diagonal that
means that every pixel as a neighbor
that is exactly the same as that same
pixel value if you're around here you
see that that's about the case for
pixels that are in the in the mid tones
but for for example dark pixels or lower
on textile you see that the
more widespread and based on the world
bunch of computation you can do on these
metrics you can actually describe the
properties of the Patel in your texture
image so if you just do that
co-occurrence matrix on its own you
don't achieve invariance rotation so
this you can do by just averaging value
scanners when you compute the values
co-occurrence matrix and this would
essentially be the co-occurrence matrix
will be working on we're working with
and this is invariant rotation which is
surely in a foursome case of texture
classification you would want to have to
be invariant to rotation so a relic has
proposed 13 features that can be
computed from this matrix it turns out
that in most experiments out of this 14
feature there's so much correlation
between them that it's classic to use a
subset of 5 so this is what I'm going to
do now you accentuate those those fives
are unnamed imaginated describe the
contrast the correlation entropy and
local homogenate I do not intend to to
have you as especially after a coffee
break to look into that too much but
once coffee kicks in maybe for later let
our stuff i would so essentially let's
let's just say that after after you are
done computing these co-occurrence
matrix and you compute these five
features you have a descriptor of your
image and that is supposed to be a
robust description that can be then fed
to a classifier if you are dealing with
color images you can extend that concept
by working in the LED color space and
essentially compute the same five
features but by looking at pair of
channel so Ln a at the same time
computer matrix get five features and L
b then l and l and so far so if you do
that you can then describe a color image
by a vector of 30 values which I do here
for this not so much of a technic
texture galaxy I guess so this is about
the theory of these features and now
let's see how they perform when we apply
them for classification task so I'd be
using this data set that was published
by nearby colleagues at the UIUC and
i'll be looking at three types of back
of woods and three types of foods the DS
training these are data set as more
categories and that but for the purpose
of this talk I'll focus on on these six
categories so we have 40 images six
types of wood what you do is actually
before you you want to use the function
classify you need to just on a training
set compute the features and tell the
system the class they belong to so
instead of me spending the time
computing them that it doesn't take too
long but it just faster to pre-compute
for the purpose of this talk and then
that training set is ready for the
function classify and this function
classify is actually takes care of
finding for you the type of classifier
that best is best suited for this data
and here it's a logistic regression and
once you have this classifier again I'm
going to load we are going to assess the
performance of it and we need a training
set which have pre computed features for
already and now we can we can see how
the height perform so what we can see
here that overall accuracy is on the
trail on the test set is eighty-four
percent and if i look at the confusion
matrix which tells me that for example
the back the first type of bark has been
recognized indeed as the
first diaper bag pretty much all the
time except for 433 samples and what you
see here is that essentially you have
probably something to look at for that
first type of food probably you want to
add data to your training set or
figurative there's something else you
would like to perform on there so I'll
be now moving on to a completely
different topic which is a law talking
about computational photography and
geometry so if you I don't know if you
have been to the bottom of the Burj
Khalifa in Dubai but it's pretty high
when you want to if you want to yourself
to have a look at it you better almost
break your neck or fall backward and
it's the same if you want to take a
picture of it you cannot just have your
camera in front of the building and hope
to get a full picture of the building
you have to tilt your camera and by
doing this you capture the entire
building but of course you introduce a
lot of distortions and it may be hard
for such a big building but what you
would like is a is to rectify this image
to make it to make it straight again so
that that is another example in the
urban environment where I guess you know
sometimes you have to all your camera
and try to take a picture above a crowd
or something and the later one you want
to automatically put it back in straight
shape so that that's what we are going
to tackle I I mean not going to all the
details of the application for the Burj
Khalifa but with a that's the start so
am i we start first with this with this
toy example of that is a very suited for
a purpose it's generated using
Mathematica if I rasterized 3d graphics
there is a actually a perspective
transformation that is going on so I
have I can just show
or the algorithm I'm going to explain
using this toy image and we want to try
to have that cube back straight up the
approach we have here is to try to
detect line so that's the little object
that we are going to work with so in
order to detect lines we first need to
make them conspicuous in the image here
the human eyes may be detecting them but
no computer will be able to do that so
once you compute here the the gradients
fill the gradient magnitude I have now
very sharp representation of of the
edges of that shape and now I can use a
function called image lines to detect
them so what image lines is going to do
is essentially going to look at all the
possible candidates in line candidates
in these pictures and figure out what is
what is the best tits what are the lines
that best fit the image so there's
various algorithm to that will I will
let you look at documentation to
understand the details of image lines
but after you are done detecting those
lines you are here I have specified
parameters so that I only get the best
lines and you see that I have indeed
detected lines that correspond to this
all the vertical axis as well as the two
of us or result all and as well as depth
so this is this is boo this is the first
part this is where computer vision folks
are not very happy because they have an
estimate of lines that you're fully is
robust and works well and now they can
derive the additional the additional
applied mathematics to to combine this
information into something something of
higher level so the thing we would like
to do is to find the entire sections of
this line and that will give what is
called the vanishing
points and if you know about the
position of these vanishing points you
can then derive further information like
we can calibrate your cameras in some
cases or rotate an object in an image so
let's compute line intersections so new
in Mathematica 10 there's a dysfunction
region intersection so we could actually
just give our lines and get a result but
unfortunately we cannot really do that
in the in this case because I guess
region intersection does what it should
so if here I have two lines that are
parallel you see that this is a this is
a vertical line and this is also a
vertical line and the region
intersection tells me that did not
intersect but in computer vision
parallel lines intersect all the time
right if you take a picture of a road
you see that all the time so actually
the intersect at the Infinity so we
cannot use that framework of region
processing right now for this
application even though it can make
sense in about another times so instead
we'll just use a you know the classic
way of computing intersections there's
two things that perhaps I should mention
in the details of its you you may want
to use the various ways of approaching
that you could use also projective
homogeneous coordinates to have perhaps
a more robust estimation but in this
case this was very nicely and you hear
what is being done is essentially
computing an intersection in Cartesian
coordinates and then returning the line
parameters as pull-up pull-up
coordinates or returning deviation from
the center of the image as well as in
anger corresponding to the slope of the
of the line another to be another aspect
is that some many times
optimizers will perform better if we
helped a bit with massaging the data and
in this case it works better if we
express the line with a coordinate
system where the center is in the the
region is in the center of the image so
I'm just changing my line so that their
into this new system and then we can
just apply the function that performs
intersection on all the possible lines
so this will be the coordinates where
lines intersect and this is very good
this is very far from the image images
perhaps less than a thousand pixel so if
you have an intersection which is that
far back that's great you want that
means that's you're probably a candidate
for a vanishing point and we have a we
have several of them so and these are
the angles that correspond to the right
so now we can just since we're
interested in putting back and putting
back buildings up we can just look at
the directions that correspond post
potentially to the vertical direction
and oh I'm sorry this was actually just
getting the direction from the possible
vanishing point you see here you may be
tempted to see three clusters 14 maybe
one direction one for another one and
perhaps one for vertical the article
horizontal and deaf actually it will be
a fallacy to run a clustering algorithm
on this data because not every image
will exhibit the three levels of
perspective many image will have two or
maybe only one or even zero so instead
we are doing a very i guess the smart
thing to do here with just the isolator
arranged where the the angle is likely
to be and we select the directions
within this range and after this you
just pretty much try to combine that
into a single angle that correspond to a
single vanishing point so here I just
select the use of Indian and we can now
just rotate that little toy into a stand
upright position so we can now apply the
exact same thing to to a real case rate
application so here I have a Rubik's
Cube and the same you can see the
perspective effect and in this case I
use controls to users contours a rich
filter that will allow to enhance the
this dark separation between the phases
and I'm just this is exactly the same
thing as we just said we just compute
lines see them and then we make sure
this lines are in the coordinate system
that will be a robust and compute
intersections and figure out the points
that that are likely to be vanishing
points and get directions for them and
over you have a straight Rubik's Cube
and I could I could do the same of
course for that one of this initial
picture i have shown at the beginning
and again the exact same thing but the
only thing that varies here that i look
at the gradient to compute my contours
that our fault line detection etc again
this is the exact same phenomena and you
see that this time we may not have
achieved that great of a straightening
so the autumn I making such process
automatic and a data set of your entire
library of thousands and thousands of
images this will be more challenging
than that there's a kind of scratching
the surface here alright so i would like
to talk about the further application
which is def map estimation from
steroids so we have we have already
talked a bit about geometry and
we're doing a little move into it so
here's the scenario you have two cameras
that take pictures of the same scene so
in that pictures this will be your your
two cameras and you see that this is a
this point x is a 3d point of the world
and it gets projected on that location
in the first image on the left and this
location X prime on the image on the
right but if you look at only this point
here and you want to know but where is
it in the right image then you have an
ambiguity because that point x is
actually the projection of all these 3d
points here and these 3d points are at a
different location in the right image so
we are going to leverage that
information to try to derive an
estimation of the of death what we want
is to estimate essentially when we look
at this point X on the image of the left
how D or deep is the actual point in the
scene that is being projected in X so
let's see how we can coerce information
from this set up into into some
information that is valuable so let's
disarm I two images so this is the left
image and this is the right image it's a
bit stage as you can see but it's
actually a not challenging that seem so
alright so I hope Kofi is kicked in now
that's the only question I have left I
think the thing we we have to find is
the something called the fundamental
matrix so beside the terminology is
essentially a matrix 3 by 3 f that
allows to map a point in one image to a
line in the second image so if I go back
very quickly to this slide here
it will map that matrix F is the matrix
that will map this point x2 that light
that blue line here so if we find this
matrix we will be able to use it to
derive information about the depth in
your inner images so the first thing we
need to do is to try to find
corresponding points in the left and
right images and then we'll solve an
equation for F so in Mathematica it's
very easy to use image key points to
derive to derive such information and I
want to emphasize that even though here
key points are being much based on local
descriptors of the appearance there is
no geometric information that is being
used when we compute these
correspondences so potentially here we
have a lot of false matches maybe even
half of them just because we do not
inject any geometric constraint in that
function so if I look at the result this
is just the first 100 points and you
know that that's pretty much a lot of
them are correct actually so is it very
good news for the for the following so
now how to estimate these fundamental
matrix F based on this set of
correspondences because the f is a
verifying this equation for every point
it is quite easy to read recast that
problem into a standard linear algebra
optimization of the least square type of
thing where you try to find a vector
that contains the flat variables of F
that explains the best this relationship
for the corresponding point I don't
think I have time to go in details but
that's a bit more complicated than that
if you just do this knifing you will
have a lot of noise in your result this
is a bit sensitive in terms of numerical
way of computing
in mathematica it's actually buried in
some context so I don't need to show the
code right now and this is our result
with this matrix F even though I have
four minutes left we are not done at
that moment because what we have here is
a matrix and we have a set of
corresponding points but we have maybe
400 of them and what we want is that we
have an estimation for every single
pixel in the image so now we are going
to see how to go from this very sparse
spouse estimation to a dance estimation
and so the first thing we do is what is
called image rectification we are doing
this because even though thanks to the
fundamental matrix I can take any point
in the right image and see the line
where it is on the left image it's very
expensive if I want to pass lines that
are diagonal and so forth instead if I
were to move my to image plane so that
they are parallel to each other then the
correspondences I will just need to scan
a result our lines if I look for the
point X on the right image I knew I just
need to look along this line to the best
match so allow meet well I hope you
trust me that this is good and all right
and after we have done this this
messaging this is this is what you get
for the rectified image on the left and
on the right and here you see that
indeed when i trace a result all lines I
get similar alignment so point here for
example is the same place on the on the
same horizontal line so let me spend a
minute explaining how we are going to
find the disparity between between the
two points the idea is that the two
images are kind of very close from each
other because they are not
taken too far apart so if there's a
little patch around the point on the
left image it should not be too
different on the right image so what we
are going to do is essentially try to
find a good match of the patch on the
left image with all the candidates on
the line in the right image so here is a
little patch around the nose of that
teddy bear and what the task is is
pretty much trying to find where where
is the best match for that nose and this
is the same scale whereas the same
position for that nose on that band that
the horizontal band so this is a we can
just compute the Euclidean distance for
every position and this will be where
the disparity will be for that very
point so for that nose here you see that
there is a difference of four pixels or
recently between the left image and the
right image so that four is the what is
called disparity and the higher it is
that meets doesn't much the highlight is
that means the closer you are from the
camera so the smaller your def is
because if you are the Infinity it
doesn't matter that your two cameras are
a bit a little bit different if you're
very close as well get the most
differences so now if I want to compute
that actually I that concept explanation
i give is too slow to implement so if
I'm willing to give some quality
degradation I can do that much quicker
and that's what I'm going to do now i
compute the disparity using the left
image and the right as a as a reference
and vice versa after that I can I can
try to reconcile this to estimate and
you see here that when it's black that
means that the two versions are two
different to be trusted so only in this
area actually I have something good here
and I do final processing just too
essentially find the best the best
estimated based on the disparity from
the left and the right and this is the
result you get if I had more time I
would I will talk more about what you
can do with that but there's another
problem I have to admit this is not very
very good as to I said that on the edges
you are not supposed to be do well with
that method and indeed but you have too
much of areas in the foreground where
it's not good enough so around the teddy
bear it's fine but that's a you know
that's pretty much the end of the talk
for today I think there will be there
will be more coming into that and I'm on
time thank you